une chose que j'aime dans le monde des monstres,
c'est qu'il est si large et que vous pouvez faire
tout ce que vous savez, nous aimons tous ce
genre, le film universitaire Les films universitaires
sont juste amusants pour s'amuser et
c'est donc beaucoup d'occasions de montrer l'humour
que vous  voir à l'université double-o pris
tout ce qui concerne l'université et les
yeux de monstre dit ce qui signifie le rendre plus gros plus
effrayant que drôle nous avons des
dortoirs monstres professeurs monstres
étudiants monstres nous monstres j'ai bloqué le
bâtiment les a rendus gros et ajouté des griffes
et des crocs à l'extérieur  quand Mike
traversait le campus, nous voulions qu'il
lève les yeux et baisse les yeux pour voir de minuscules
monstres d'énormes monstres pourquoi vouloir des
monstres nageurs et puis bien sûr
il y a les fraternités et la sororité
c'est aussi un film universitaire c'est fou
et c'est vraiment drôle
bien gee  Je sais, merci d'avoir
coupé, pourquoi c'était comme abandonner l'
omelette sautée, mais était-ce